das Paradies ist ein Ort an dem jeder
Zug einen Anschluss hat so wie in diesem
Imagefilm der Deutschen Bahn
doch die Realität sieht leider ein wenig
anders aus
39 Minuten
[Musik]
wir sind einem Gerücht gefolgt angeblich
soll es in diesem Land Menschen geben
die mit der Deutschen Bahn nicht
zufrieden sind das schauen wir uns mal
an aber warum haben wir uns diese
bahnklamotten angezogen damit wir einmal
seriös Aussehen ja stimmt wir wollen mal
Feedback einholen wie zufrieden sind Sie
denn mit der Deutschen Bahn
was heißt das genau die Geste schlecht
ich meine wenn die Ansage sagt jetzt
fahren der Zug steht bereit und auf dem
Gleis ist nicht dass die hören auf die
Ansagen die benutzen wir eigentlich
unter anderem so ein bisschen Spaß auch
im Alltag zu haben weil wir haben ja
dann Überwachungskameras da können wir
gucken läuft wirklich so Gleis 4
das sind ihre 10 20 schönsten Bahn
erleben die schönste Geschichte gestern
vor der Zukunft
40 Minuten Verspätung
ich hatte mal über 300 Minuten dann
machen Sie hier einen Aufstand
Beschwerden sich bei uns für 40 Minuten
dafür kommen Sie jetzt zu unverschämter
es wird immer nur Gemecker kommen musste
ist der ICE ausgefallen und die Deutsche
Bahn hat uns dann auch ein Frühstück
eingeladen ach ja Mensch
saßen schöner Tag ja schönes Frühstück
so mein Auto steht in der Garage
tatsächlich
komme ja das ist doch cool
Deutsche Bahn irgendwo kommt man immer
an
die Deutsche Bahn AG gehört zu 100% im
Staat ist mit über 200.000 Mitarbeitern
einer der größten Arbeitgeber
Deutschlands und beförderte allein
letztes Jahr 132 Millionen Menschen im
Fernverkehr mit einer sagenhaften
Pünktlichkeit von
65%
zu spät war also jeder dritte Zug doch
wie konnte so weit kommen 1994 das Jahr
der Bahn Reform Pünktlichkeitsquote
heute unvorstellbare 90% doch dann soll
die Bahn an die Börse und was viele
nicht wissen Börse das ist ein anderes
Wort für kaputt sparen denn jetzt kommt
alles unentable einfach weg 1994 hatte
die Deutsche Bahn ein Betriebsnetz von
mehr als 41000 km Länge heute sind es
nur noch rund 33.000 und da wir seitdem
auch die Hälfte aller weichen abgebaut
haben konnten wir das deutsche
Weltkulturerbe Stau auf die Schiene
übertragen Mann ist das deprimierend
schnell was lustiges wir haben für
kleines Geld einen Arbeitslosen
Moderator engagiert damit er uns echte
Bahn Durchsagen vorliest
sehr geehrte Fahrgäste heute endet der
Zug außer planmäßig in Köln Hauptbahnhof
Grund ist dass der Zug dringend in die
Werkstatt muss wir sind froh wenn wir
Köln überhaupt erreichen der Lokführer
ist wegen eines anderen verspäteten
Zuges noch nicht eingetroffen wir
blockieren gerade das Gleis für seinen
Zug wir sind selbst gespannt wie das
aufgelöst wird
weißt du was wir jetzt echt brauchen ja
endlich mal jemand der sich auskennt ein
echten Bahnexperten huch da ist ja einer
und was für einer Professor Böttger er
empfängt uns in seinem Aufzug hör auf
mit den Wortspielen
jetzt haben wir ja aktuell die
schlechteste Lage die ist eigentlich
jemals gab bei der Deutschen Bahn
sind
es muss sich doch radikal was ändern
oder
ja müsste es und unten also konjunktiv
ist aber wenn man jetzt muss man da
hingekommen es fahren immer mehr Züge ja
also wir haben jedes Jahr etwa 0,7% mehr
Züge auf dem Netz seit 20 Jahren das
wirkt erstmal wenig aber wenn man sagt
man baut keine neue Infrastruktur und
jedes Jahr kommt ein Prozent dazu an
Leistung irgendwas ist das Netz voll und
das kann man beim besten Willen eben
nicht über Nacht beheben Deutschland
investiert ja pro Jahr 124 € Pro Burger
in die Bahn wie stehen wir da im
internationalen Vergleich
ganz weit hinten klar ist Deutschland
investiert wenig und zu wenig und hat
eben auch in den letzten Jahren die
Investitionen weiter zurückgefahren und
das ist sicherlich einer der Kernpunkte
für den schlechten Zustand unseres
Netzes aber warum warum investiert
Deutschland so wenig in die Schule wir
investieren ja auch zu wenig in Schulen
in Straßen in Wasserstraße
ich glaube auch ein bisschen eben der
politische Mechanismus sondern sagt alle
Dinge die eben Investitionen sind die
wirken erst langfristig weil eben die
kurzfristigen Sachen ja die helfen einem
bei der nächsten Wahl ja und die
Investition helfen nur dem Nachfolger
das heißt man muss der Ampel nur
versprechen ihr dürft jetzt 20 Jahre an
der Macht bleiben
und dann wird es langfristig alles gut
war dein bester Gag heute
[Gelächter]
beim FDP Parteitag gelandet auf der
Suche nach unserem Verkehrsminister
Volker Wissing aber wo ist denn nur egal
spreche ich halt erstmal mit diesem
anderen Typen von der FDP könnten Sie
sich vorstellen nach ihrer Zeit in der
Politik Lokführer zu werden
wir haben Personal ich fürchte nach
meiner Zeit in der Politik mit den
weiteren Fortschritten bei der
künstlichen Intelligenz ob es dann
überhaupt noch Lokführer gibt ich habe
ich habe also vor noch ein bisschen
länger Politik die Menschen bei der FDP
Nerven oder Lokführer werden ist doch
auch egal oder
thank you for traveling des Deutschen
Bahn der Mann wird Lokführer ich möchte
jetzt hier aber auch mal mit Klischees
aufräumen natürlich ist die FDP nicht
nur eine Porsche Partei das sieht man
auch am riesigen Andrang hier am Stand
der Deutschen Bahn
[Musik]
sie haben die Deutsche Bahn zu Chefsache
erklärt jetzt die schlechte Nachricht
die schlechte Nachricht ist weil sie das
glaube ich noch nicht mitbekommen haben
sie sind der Chef der sich jetzt darum
kümmern muss
und deswegen der Bundesverkehrsminister
und kümmere ich mich natürlich um die um
die Deutsche Bahn wir haben
rekordinvestitionen vor und wir müssen
natürlich jetzt auch sehen dass diese
dieser netzzustand den wir haben so
nicht bleiben kann jetzt werden ja im
Haushalt 2023 12 Milliarden für Bundes
Fernstraßen ausgegeben nur 9 Milliarden
für bundesschienenwege ich habe mir
ersten Gag überlegt dazu aber ich dachte
es ist vielleicht lustiger wenn ihr
einfach den Koalitionsvertrag zitiere
wir wollen erheblich mehr
in die Schiene als in die Straße und
viel schöner ist es noch wenn sie sich
den letzten
koalitionsausschussbeschluss anschauen
und da steht ja erheblich mehr drin da
steht nämlich die Zahl von 45 Milliarden
drin und auch noch nicht geklärt ist
finanziert werden soll diese Lkw-Maut
reicht ja nicht ne naja aber wenn sie
alleine die Einnahmen der Lkw-Maut sind
und sie nehmen die Einnahmen der LK
zusätzlich zu dem was da jetzt schon im
Entwurf steht dann haben sie erheblich
mehr
investieren und gleichzeitig tun wir das
Wasser was wir vor zu Beginn der
Regierungszeit auch zugesagt haben und
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben ist
eigentlich eine gute Nachricht darf ich
noch einen Fakt zum Ende sagen und zwar
habe ich gelesen 2022 wurden 74 km
Schiene neu gebaut und 10.000 km Straße
das war der Fakt den Jahr einfach nur
auf dem Weg gehen wollte und kann ich
Ihnen sagen das wollen wir auch ändern
weil wir durch diesen letzten Beschluss
im Koalitionsausschuss jetzt ein
deutliches beschleunigungskonzept auch
für den Schienenausbau vorgelegt haben
trotzdem letztes Jahr 74 km Schiene 10
000 km Straße vielen Dank für das
Gespräch Herr scheuer
sehr witzig und wiesen sie noch mal
puh von so ein Parteitag muss ich mich
erstmal erholen ich treffe meinen
langjährigen yoga-partner Klaus ein ganz
entspannter Typ zufällig ist er auch
Chef der Gewerkschaft der Lokführer der
Klaus will selski ich habe mir nämlich
extra für sie eine eigene Yogaübung
ausgedacht so da muss man da oben gucken
und mit der Faust auf die Matte
schreiben das ist sehr auf die
verspätungsanzeige blickende Fahrgast
die Haltung nicht einnehmen weil dann
würde der Bahnvorstand Frau locken sie
sind nämlich wieselski sie in die Knie
gegangen und das wird nicht passieren
glauben Sie denn der neue
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing kriegt
die Probleme endlich in den Griff ich
habe große Hoffnungen in den
Verkehrsminister gesetzt jetzt dauert
mir es ehrlich gesagt viel zu lange und
ich habe so das dumpfe Gefühl dass der
Bahnvorstand dem Minister wieder
beigebracht hat wie es zu gehen hat also
der Schwanz wedelt wieder mit dem Hund
und ähm der Schwanz hier in der Schwanz
ist normalerweise der Vorstand der DB
die haben auszuführen was da Eigentümer
will Herr wissen ist mir zu zögerlich
die Entscheidung für die Infrastruktur
muss fallen und zwar jetzt aber mal kurz
zu Entspannung noch eine Yogaübung
dazwischen schieben ganz einfach das
habe ich mir erstmal an welche Übung sie
machen uns ganz gelassen aus das ist
eine gute Idee ja schließen die Augen
und machen nichts wir machen absolut
nicht die Übung heißt der
Verkehrsminister
spüren sie einfach wie die Energie von
Volker Wissingen sie reinfließt also da
spüre ich nicht ja das ist ja der Sinn
der Sache
einmal so entspannt sein wie Volker
Wissing
einmal so entspannt sein wie andreas
Scheuer
einmal so entspannt sein wie Alexa da
Dobrindt ich würde gerne einmal
entspannt mit geschlossenen Augen im
Zügen sitzen und die Zugbegleiter der
Menschen verdicken wir sind pünktlich
unterwegs wir erreichen den nächsten
Bahnhof pünktlich wir werden auch alle
Reisenden befördern können das ist so
meine Zukunft eine komplette Yogaübung
kaputt mit ihrem unrealistischen
Schwachsinn ich bin kein Träumer aber
ich bin Optimist wir wissen doch beides
wird nie kommen ich weiß es wird kommen
nein es wird nicht kommen deshalb bin
ich vorsichtshalber mit dem Rad gefahren
zur bahnbetriebszentrale in Duisburg ich
sag mal so die paar Züge die sie hier
koordinieren müssen come on das kann ja
wohl nicht so schwer sein also hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen haben wir
werktäglich im Schnitt so knapp über
8.000 Zugfahrten die wir überwachen und
koordinieren müssen und die potentiell
natürlich auch ähm ja mit denen immer
irgendwas sein kann wenn man häufiger in
NRW unterwegs ist mit der Bahn so wie
ich dann wundert man sich schon dass es
hier ja offensichtlich Überwachung
Koordination und Strategie gibt ich bin
baff ja und das machen wir mit über 100
Menschen krass rund um die Uhr ja ja nur
für sie und sie merken es nicht
kann man sagen das ist hier alles ein
großes Strategiespiel nur ohne Gewinner
ich glaube es gibt ganz viele Gewinner
ich bin es meistens nicht ja vielleicht
kommen Sie in die Rolle irgendwann rein
aber bei der Anzahl an Fahrgästen die
wir täglich im Westen auf der Schiene
haben schaffen das glaube ich immer noch
das am Ende des Tages natürlich auch
Verlierer dabei sind dass das ist so ja
aber ich glaube schon dass wir im Großen
und Ganzen eine ganze Menge wegräumen
jetzt habe ich gerade auch ein bisschen
mit gehört es kam gerade eine
Katastrophenmeldung rein und zwar wurde
die Hohenzollernbrücke gesperrt wegen
eines Pudels da frage ich mich muss man
die Brücke sperren wegen eines Pudels es
ist ein Pudel es ist ein Pudel genau
Hunde
[Gelächter]
das möchte ich nicht kommentieren ich
will ja nicht als da kann ich kein
Urteil sehen aber die können da nicht
einfach durch Brettern nein das geht
nicht das machen wir nicht
für dich
[Musik]
ja genau wichtigste Frage vorweg was ist
jetzt mit dem Pudel also die Strecke ist
wieder freigegeben worden ob der Pudel
aufgegriffen wurde das weiß ich leider
nicht ja ja aber er ist zumindest nicht
mehr zu sehen und dass das sieht man
jetzt hier auch zur tatsächlich erst
Meldung xxx meldet einen Hund Klammer
auf Pudel Klammer zu und was bedeutet
diese Zahl 9 das sind die
zusatzverspätung das bedeutet wir haben
jetzt 996 Minuten Verspätung wegen des
Pudels er ist richtig genau der hat das
eingebrochen auf 47 Züge verteilt an
alles wegen des Pudels
aber kriegt dann auch so eine Halteren
Ärger eigentlich
immer mehr ich will dir einfach ein
bisschen zu reinbringen dann auch ein
Wortspiel natürlich ich will dass es
einfach läuft ich müsste einmal ans
telefonieren ne nein
[Musik]
ist ja hallo also zehn vier sieben
zwanzig auf 38 in Euskirchen wir haben
in Bonn reichen Störung
auf 25
Richtung Godesberg haben wir da
eingleisig bitte auf 10438
genau 104 27 ist ja macht ja auch schon
häufiger Probleme ja das sind jetzt
eigentlich die Nachwirkungen aus dem
Pudel
es folgt Werbung Horror Fans aufgepasst
vergessen Sie es von Stephen King der
neueste Schocker heißt Netz
Zustandsbericht der Deutschen Bahn über
20 Seiten pures grauen denn 26% aller
weichen 42 % aller Bahnübergänge und 48
% aller stellwerwerke sind in einem
schlechten mangelhaften oder
ungenügenden Zustand schlagen Sie jetzt
zu die Instandsetzung kostet uns nur 89
Milliarden Euro zu verdanken haben wir
das alles einer Boyband namens CSU
bestehend aus dem Pianisten Peter
Ramsauer dem luftgitarrenspieler
Alexander Dobrindt und dem DJ an die
Steuer die hobbymäßig von 2009 bis 2021
Bundesverkehrsminister waren
Kritiker sind jedenfalls begeistert so
urteilt der Bundesrechnungshof das an
Kapazitätsgrenzen stoßende Schienennetz
inzwischen
Wandtattoo im Verkehrsministerium tja
und jetzt
[Musik]
lieber noch eine Bahn Durchsage leider
wissen wir nicht ob der nächste Halt
Dortmund oder Essen ist laut meinen
Informationen halten wir in Bochum in
der Leitstelle geht keiner ans Telefon
und der Lokführer weiß auch nicht genau
wir melden uns wenn wir mehr wissen
danke Oliver Potsdam hier im
Kaiserbahnhof treffen wir keinen
geringeren als den Konzernsprecher der
Deutschen Bahn Achim Staus für ihn haben
wir ein eigenes Brettspiel entwickelt
mit dem schönen Titel mensch ärgere Dich
haben sie eine Ahnung wie wir auf den
Titel gekommen sind ist mir völlig fremd
ich möchte aber betonen was sie hier
zeigen ist nicht das Streckennetz der
Deutschen Bahn das ist unvollständig wir
haben das also
[Applaus]
das längste Strecken als Europas das ist
auch ein ganz einfaches Spiel es ist
einfach nur ja sie würfeln Sie gehen
Felder vor wenn Sie auf einem
Fragezeichen sind Ereignis fällt Karte
ziehen wenn Sie auf einer Stadt sind
auch eine Karte ziehen sie müssen
eigentlich immer noch haben eigentlich
der Sinn des Spieles alles kann
passieren es ist also wie bei der
Deutschen Bahn
und es wird ein gutes Ende nehmen
[Musik]
ich nehme rot
daneben und muss natürlich auch eine
Ereigniskarte ziehen aufgrund von
Bauarbeiten besteht nur eingleisiger
streckenbetrieb sie müssen einem
entgegenkommenden Zug abwarten der hat
leider Verspätung zwei Runden aussetzen
das ist bitter hängt aber wirklich damit
zusammen dass wir bauen müssen wir bauen
etwa 1000 Baustellen pro Tag
gleichzeitig das ist Spitzen wert auch
wenn die Pünktlichkeit wirklich
bescheiden ist da will ich gar nicht
drum reden das war im letzten Jahr nicht
akzeptabel und war ja auch der Grund
warum wir uns zu dieser Generalsanierung
entschlossen haben merken auf der
anderen Seite dass die Kunden
Zufriedenheit vergleichsweise noch gut
ist und ja die Menschen laufen
doch aber ich hatte eine klare Antwort
offen die Antwort nee aber ist in der
Tat so die auf Deutschland die Menschen
rennen uns die Bude ein also ganz
schlecht und das sein wir haben in haben
die Menschen die Bude einrennen lieber
zu müssen von A nach B kommt ja aber es
gibt ja auch viele die keine Alternative
haben also naja es gibt schon viele die
motorisiert sind ja aber wenn ich jetzt
eine lange Strecke fahre wenn ich mir
überlege Berlin München also ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass ich dann die Bahn
nehme weil ich die Bahn super geil finde
weil alles funktioniert sondern man
nimmt die Bahn weil ich keinen Bock hab
acht Stunden im Auto zu sitzen ja und
Berlin München ist auch ein gutes
Beispiel das ist nämlich eine Strecke
auf der werden überdurchschnittlich hoch
Pünktlichkeit haben warum weil die
Strecke neu gebaut ist das heißt ich
sollte nach München ziehen damit ich
dann besser nach Berlin kommen und
täglich pendeln kein Problem unter vier
Stunden
zwei zwei ich bin der grüne von Hamburg
nach Bremen genau
letztes Jahr musste die Bahn
Entschädigungen im Rekordwert von
92,7 Millionen Euro an ihre Kunden
zahlen falls einer von den Spielern bei
der Bahn arbeitet zahlt er den anderen
sofort symbolisch fünf Euro oder setzt
eine Runde aus dann bin ich natürlich
fürs aussetzen
einmal hat mir gehofft dass wir von der
Bahn was kriegen ist ja auch wirklich
Zufall dass jetzt hier ein Spieler von
der Bahn dabei
konnte keiner mit Rechnen überschätzen
vielleicht auch meine finanziellen
Möglichkeiten keinen Bonus wie jetzt mal
schön noch mal wie viel was über 1,2
Millionen ja das ist ja sinnvoll dass
das Führungskräfte jetzt kein starres
Gehalt bekommt
[Musik]
wie viel wäre es bei Erfolg gewesen ja
also kriegen jetzt kein Geld oder kein
Geld hatte ich glaube ich deutlich
ausgedrückt oder
[Musik]
drei es gibt doch nicht wir stehen alle
jetzt auf diesen das ist ja mega
spannend ja Leute das ist es ist
unfassbar spannend ist auch mal damit
wir das ein bisschen erzeugen können
gut ja ich glaube man sieht ist nicht
mehr zu verhindern
ach genau genau ins Ziel hättet ihr eins
zwei und sie haben gewonnen wie
glücklich sind sie einer der schönsten
Momente meines Lebens ist es so schlimm
ich kann vielleicht nicht so ausdrücken
sie werden zum Bahnchef befördert und
genehmigen sich erstmal einen Bonus von
über 1,2 Millionen Euro kaufen sich
davon einen Porsche und müssen nie
wieder baden fahren gratulation
sieht man einmal 7 Stunden mit dem
bahnkonzernsprecher mensch ärgere Dich
und schon verpasst man fast seinen Zug
aber jetzt ist doch alles gut oder
geänderte Wagen rein junge okay aber
jetzt ist alles gut
aber jetzt rein hier in den Zug in
welchen denn nein den hier
so heulen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommen
und ich habe das Gefühl dass wir hier
nicht mehr wegkommen müssen
läuft nicht gut
[Musik]
es gab gerade eine schlechte Meldung es
gab eine Durchsage wir haben den Kontakt
zur Außenwelt verloren mit der Funk ist
ausgefallen der Funk ist ausgefallen das
ist kein Scherz jetzt gibt es eine was
eine drehwendung eine drehwerdung das
heißt wir fahren zurück nach Berlin 40
bis 50 Minuten Verspätung Minimum
[Musik]
ja wir stehen jetzt hier immer noch
irgendwo vor Spandau aber wir wollen
auch nicht nur die ganze Zeit Aussage
machen auch mal die anderen die Normalos
lustiger Zufall dass wir uns gesehen
haben aber ich meine ich glaube der
Bahnsprecher hat euch wahrscheinlich
erzählt läuft alles klar Vorschläge die
CDU braucht es gar nicht ich würde sagen
hier ist vielleicht ein belegt dass man
doch was machen muss
schon absurd oder ja ich meine ist
wirklich ärgerlich jetzt die Kollegin
Sandra Maischberger fürchtet
wahrscheinlich jetzt in die Sendung wenn
ich sie müssen aber
ich bin guter Hoffnung dass das
irgendwie noch das alles machen können
nicht zum Beispiel wenigstens eine gute
Nachricht ach so hätte die CDU da mal
was vorher getan oder hättet also ja wir
haben nicht ganz alleine regiert aber
investieren ist natürlich ein super
Thema hier erstmal im Zug wir haben die
Zeit würde ich sagen wollen wir drei uns
einfach mal bedanken bei den CSU
Verkehrsminister
das weiß ich
[Musik]
ja wir sitzen immer noch in irgendeinem
Zug gefahren irgendwohin wir fahren
bestehen bestehen
wollen sie Ort
[Musik]
und neben anderen Zug dann aus auf das
Bahnhof das weiß ich nicht ja
das musst
du denn da ich Filme
schlecht aussehende Aufnahmen werden
nicht akzeptiert
ist ab in den neuen Zug in den
evakuierungszug
39 Minuten
[Musik]
9 Stunden Zugfahrt liegen hinter uns wir
haben es nach Köln geschafft
so kann es nicht weitergehen die Bahn
braucht endlich mehr Kompetenz damit
kann ich zwar nicht dienen aber ich bin
ja eh gerade wieder in Köln von daher
Zug ahoi das sagt man doch so oder hallo
leute macht euch keine Sorgen ich bin da
das ist gut
wir wollten ganz kurz fragen ob alles da
ist wirklich alles da und auch alles
cool alles cool der Kaffee ist warm
ist das Fernsehen funktioniert alles
[Musik]
nein das kriege ich hin
alles gut soll ich dich an die Hand
nehmen
also es sieht jetzt so aus würde ich
mich blöd anstellen aber es ist nicht
gespielt ich finde es super hart ja
lachen sie mich nur aus hallo
sie sind heute meine absoluter
Lieblingsgast
sind sie wirklich
sie sind heute mein absoluter
lieblingsgeist schon gesagt ja gut klar
das ist natürlich auch eine gewisse
Taktik die ich hier fahre hallo Sie sind
heute mein absoluter lieblingsgeist die
Kekse sind umsonst sie dürfen aber
trotzdem Trinkgeld geben wenn in der
Service zusagt ich will keinen Druck
machen
Deutsche Bundesbahn you love it really
yes
das ist jetzt ein Schauspieler den ihr
engagiert habt wahrscheinlich ne ich
wohne in Zürich das heißt sie sind
Schweizer müssen mit der Deutschen Bahn
fahren
wir müssen das wieder gut machen nehmen
Sie die Kekse doch gut machen die Dame
kommt aus der Schweiz ist doch was ganz
anderes gewohnt
vergessen ich möchte Sie heute auf das
gastronomische Angebote im Zug
aufmerksam machen ich empfehle Ihnen
heute den deftigen Linseneintopf
Tageslicht kann Ihnen sagen dieser
Linseneintopf der schmeckt wie
hausgemacht
Mutter diesen Eintopf selber auf der
Herdplatte gebrutzelt ich hoffe Sie
haben die Zeit ich muss Ihnen sagen der
beste Linseneintopf der ist der von
meiner Mutter aber auf Platz 2 kommt
direkt der der Platz 2 kommt der von
meiner Großmutter aber auf Platz drei
kommt der Linseneintopf von
Deutschland aber ich glaube die Leute
wissen jetzt dass das Lieblingsgericht
ist
[Musik]
wir haben lecker lecker
in Lütjenburg kennt dein legendären
Linseneintopf übrigens niemand hä warum
nicht ja hier hält schon lange kein zu
mehr die Gleise wurden nämlich nach der
Wende einfach stillgelegt aber jetzt
wird die Strecke reaktiviert natürlich
nicht von der Bahn sondern von einem
privaten Verein sie sind jetzt schon
seit 30 Jahren ohne Schienennetz quasi
genau
also Bürgermeister zu sein ohne jetzt
Bahnanbindung das ist schon peinlich ja
es geht viel mehr darum dass wir unsere
Region die Stadt Lütjenburg wieder ans
Deutsche Schienennetz angeschlossen
wissen möchten weil ich schon glaube
dass das ähm in der heutigen Zeit aus
Umwelt Klimaschutz Gründen eine gute
Maßnahme wäre das ist ja ein privater
Verein der das macht also die Deutsche
Bahn macht's nicht ne ja wir sehen ja
seit 30 Jahren dass man sich auf die
Deutsche Bahn nicht verlassen kann und
von daher finde ich das sehr schön dass
dieser Verein sich gegründet hat und das
ganze jetzt in die Hand nimmt die Hälfte
der Weichen wurden rückgebaut seit 1994
und eine dieser weichen ist die
anschlussweiche von Malente nach
Lütjenburg die Herr medorn aus welchen
Gründen auch immer
ja das würde ich auch kennenlernen
weichen Pflastern seinen Weg könnte man
sagen ja
hier sehen Sie deutsche Infrastruktur
aufgegeben und liegen gelassen auf einen
Zug kann man hier lange warten das will
Heiner Monheim ändern
ich habe immer gesagt das wäre so wie
mit mir jedes zweite Autobahnkreuz und
jede zweite Abfahrt schließen jetzt
haben wir das Problem wir haben eine
Bahn die vorne und hinten nicht
funktioniert und die vor allem
klimapolitisch alle Hausaufgaben
versäumt um schneller zu werden braucht
man nicht Hochgeschwindigkeit sondern um
schneller zu werden braucht man kürzere
Wege zum Bahnhof wir brauchen mehr
Bahnhöfe mehr Haltepunkte in dichteres
Netz dann können wir Verkehrswende
machen mit unserem paar
Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecken die wir
gerade mit aber Milliarden und aber
Milliarden und mit unseren
spekulationsprojekten wie Stuttgart 21
oder Hamburg Altona mit diesem Projekten
machen wir die Bahn nicht besser sondern
wir machen sie schlechter und wir
schmeißen sehr viel Geld zum Fenster
raus was man hier eigentlich brauchen
würde wie kam sie denn auf die Idee die
Strecke zu reaktivieren also ich komme
auf die Idee indem ich im Wald spazieren
gegangen bin und über die Strecke
gestolpert bin ich hatte einen zufällig
gefunden oder zufällig gefunden das
heißt wenn wir eine erfolgreiche
Verkehrswende wollen sollten wir sie in
ganz Deutschland spazieren gehen lassen
bald fahren wir wieder Bahn bis dahin
aber erstmal drei Sinnen damit die
Strecke in der Zwischenzeit nicht wieder
im Wald verschwindet und jemand drüber
stolpert hallo
wir sind ja quasi der jüngste Bahnchef
Deutschlands klingt erstmal wieder
Beleidigung ja tatsächlich war eben die
Idee so ein bisschen noch was der Note
herausgefunden
sein will sondern dass ich manchmal
selber auch jetzt zurückdenke
was denn da passiert wenn die Deutsche
Bahn selber eine Bahnstrecke
reaktivieren will dann muss die
sogenannte Kosten Nutzenbewertung ja
stimmen hätte die hier gestimmt
ja das äh ganz interessante Frage weil
tatsächlich so diese Kosten Nutzen
Bewertungen die soll ja angeblich
beweisen auf eine Bahnstrecke
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden kann
oder für alle Zeiten nicht mehr
gebraucht wird und ich halte das eine
riesengroße Quatsch weil wir in einer
Base dermaßen verändert ähm welche
Infrastruktur die ja für über Jahrzehnte
betrachtet werden das heißt der
standardisierte Bewertung heute kann
doch gar nicht vorhersagen was in 20 30
40 50 Jahren Bewegungen sind die
verändern
in einem Wort ihre kostenlosen Bewertung
der kostenlosen Bewertung
en aber jetzt endet das gleiche ja
einfach ja das hier war meine Bahnhof
okay
Parkplatz besser kann man deutsche
Verkehrspolitik aber auch nicht
zusammenfassen ne
die Deutsche Bahn hat allein bis 2027
einen Investitionsbedarf an unfassbaren
88 Milliarden Euro finanziert hat die
Ampel aber bisher nur 43 Milliarden
weshalb sich kluge Köpfe die Frage
stellen wird das reichen ah also da
würde ich sagen nein oder ganz
Anschlussfrage wird der Finanzminister
die restlichen 45 Milliarden noch
nachschießen also da würde ich sagen
nein wieder richtig denn das zusätzliche
Geld kommt nur soweit finanziell
darstellbar gleichzeitig will die Ampel
aber die Fahrgastzahlen bis 2030
verdoppeln
apropos unrealistische Ziele erst 61%
unseres Bahnnetzes sind elektrifiziert
die Ampel will bis
2030/75% schaffen doch dafür müssten wir
500 Kilometer Strecke pro Jahr
elektrifizieren 2022 waren es aber nur
56 Kilometer naja vielleicht können wir
die ganzen Dieselloks ja mit efues
betreiben
eine pfiffige Idee auch der für 2030
geplante Taktfahrplan wo große
Knotenpunkte immer zur halben und zur
vollen Stunde angefahren werden musste
jetzt verschoben werden eben dieser
Deutschlandtag kommt jetzt 2017 euer
Ernst ja hat schwarze Sekretär teurer
dafür auch öffentlich durch das Prügel
bezogen dass er ihm gesagt hat wir sind
mit dem deutschland-takt 2017 ungefähr
fertig
genau also normalerweise normalerweise
sieht man zu dass diese diese
Sachverhalt nicht öffentlich gesagt wird
ja und deswegen werden zum Beispiel auch
in den Projektlisten des
Verkehrsministeriums grundsätzlich keine
Summens heilen gemacht bei Summenzeilen
sind gefährlich dann könnte jeder
einfach unter Nutzung eines dreisatzes
so eine Berechnung anstellen und das
will man natürlich gerne verhindern aber
das heißt 2017 heißt ja Lutz muss ich
das Wort deutschlandtakt nicht merken
also ich bin einfach tot also erstmal
ganz ganz im Ernst ich überlege also ich
werde es nicht erleben in Deutschland
richtig so das Teil deprimieren also wie
gesagt das ist eine Frage des Wortes man
kann
ja vielleicht auch irgendwann mal was
anderes als Deutschland bezeichnen das
heißt also wenn wir den jetzigen Zustand
einfach als Deutschland Takt bezeichnen
dann können wir genau früher erreichen
genau ja apropos Deutschland Takt wer
hat es erfunden die Holländer fast die
Schweizer und darum fahren wir jetzt mal
hin na hat der Zug etwas verspäten nein
Walter finkbona ist ein Urgestein der
Schweizer Bahn und wartet auf uns im
Eisenbahn Betriebslabor er lebt
eigentlich im Paradies hat nur leider
Verwandtschaft in Deutschland
ist denn Spaß durch Deutschland zu
fahren mit der Eisenbahn ich muss jetzt
sagen ich fahre sehr gerne in
Deutschland weil ich dann Zeit nehme das
brauchte
Gegenteil in der Schweiz gibt es eine
Pünktlichkeitsquote von
93%. 97%, wenn man die Anschlüsse
rechnet
zwei verschiedene und die Anschlüsse
sind ja wichtig denn nur wenn du einen
guten Anschluss hast im Leben aber auch
bei reisenbahn mit dem Bus dann
funktioniert das sind wir als 97 %. okay
Entschuldigung und
das ist ja in der Schweiz so ab 3
Minuten gilt als verspätet in
Deutschland ab sechs Minuten das heißt
wir werden ja eigentlich der unsere viel
schlecht man muss auch sagen Deutschland
ist ein bisschen länger das Schweiz es
stimmt doch dass äh hinter der Schweizer
Grenze immer Ersatzzüge bereitstehen
oder also wird ich muss also wenn aus
Deutschland Züge in die Schweiz fahren
rechnet die Schweiz schon damit dass wir
verspätet sind und stellt an der ganzen
Ersatz zu bleiben
dann haben die Kunden von Basel nach
Zürich nach Zürich nach Basel haben dann
sofort Zug das ist wichtig
lachen die Schweizer eigentlich über die
Deutsche Bahn
nie über den großen Nachbar Lachen das
ist der liegt ja nicht unsere DNA nein
natürlich nicht
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir in Deutschland erst 61%
des gesamten Schienennetzes
elektrifiziert die Schweiz ist ja
überall Vorbild ich schätze ihr seid bei
80 90 Prozent unsere Prozent ach 100
natürlich 100%
ja das war schön
aber am Ende bleiben wie immer drei
Fragen offen
schafft es Philipp Anton noch pünktlich
z.B Ärger
[Applaus]
aus zum Mitarbeiter des Monats gewählt
Lutz
wo bist du Karin Hildegard das war so
schön bei Euch
und freuen Sie sich auch schon so auf
das Jahr 2017
[Musik]
und wie kommen wir jetzt nach Hause das
ZDF hat gesagt wir kriegen das neue
deutschlandticket erst wenn 49 Leute in
der nächsten Minute den Kanal abonnieren
also alles wie immer warten
[Musik]